hello, student nurses.
I'm student nurse braille.
I'm back. so for today I will be discussing to you
and presenting to you on how I create my
family nursing care plan.
so many time family health problem.
family nursing problem.
goal of care
objective of care nursing intervention.
that rationale method of family contact resources
and the evaluation
so it's a family health problem.
nothing little nothing
but elegade subjective and objective data.
so presence of health right?
so accident hazards
tears without hand that I think objective.
so but did nothing
allegrating subjective nothing
so any family nursing problem.
did you not in my volume first level
and second level assessment.
so in ability to provide a home environment
conducive to health maintenance
and personal development.
due to the lack of knowledge
on dangerous construction materials
that can cause
so you I took a single risk for folding
so any objective of care.
so your family will know
the importance of a safe environment.
but it was an hazard and accident
second mugging our cellar
ineligible enough
some are hazards
but my prevent on any accidents.
so nursing intervention
supermark provide time information or safety.
but I'm a prevent injury
and next we need to discuss the supervision
unprevented measures signing method of family contact
putting home visit
so by the time you to mcglige on flyers
visual aid spider man
big picture
no me small problem.
so resources required.
so lost local resources
and approve and modify facilities
in home separate time and effort numbered to the ti
and the family
partially met or fully met.
so the stairs without handle
can cause accident in the family.
so you learn the passing
the long term family nursing problem.
nothing about a hazard those young stairs.
and if ever if I connect correct.
you know in time
I'm going and if every now
you can comment a comment box.
and I hope you are all safe.
god bless and